[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM SNEATH:
Hopefully, you've now
seen how Flutter is beautiful,
fast, productive, and open.
You've seen how designers and
developers can collaborate
to build native mobile apps.
You've seen how the ecosystem
extends Flutter with plugins
from companies like Square.
And you've seen tools like
2Dimensions Flare and Nevercode
that amplify the
power of Flutter.
But we're not quite done.
Flutter was not conceived as
an SDK for iOS and Android.
Our vision for Flutter
is to be a portable UI
toolkit that can go wherever
you need to paint pixels.
The Flutter engine is
inherently cross-platform,
and it can be embedded
in all kinds of hardware.
Just last week, we
shared an example
of porting Flutter to
run on Raspberry Pi,
running directly on
the Broadcom hardware
rather than using an
intermediary layer
like Linux or X11.
We believe Flutter is a useful
building block for these kinds
of embedded scenarios.
And perhaps in the future, we'll
see Flutter powering things
like automotive displays or
other IoT kinds of devices.
Another very practical
example of how
we are already
going beyond mobile
is Flutter Desktop Embedding.
This is an open
source project that
enables Flutter apps to run
on Mac, Linux, and Windows.
We've been working on
Flutter Desktop Embedding
in the open for
a few months now,
and we're pretty happy with
how it's coming on together.
This lets you do
things like take
your basic starter
application that you
get when you create a Flutter
project and run it on a Mac.
So here's the usual app here,
and you can imagine, you know,
you can [? plus ?] and see
how the number increments.
And in fact, when we were
putting this presentation
together, we were
thinking, how could we
make our slides as
beautiful as possible?
So we built the entire
presentation in Flutter.
[APPLAUSE]
Everything you've
seen so far has
been run on the Mac
implementation of Flutter.
The app has been built by
a company called Very Good
Ventures, who are a New
York-based mobile studio who
exclusively focus on developing
beautiful Flutter experiences.
We plan to open source
this software soon.
But that's not all.
There is one other
place we'd like
to go with Flutter that really
demonstrates the groundbreaking
potential of this technology.
And you know,
before I get there,
I have to take a moment--
[LAUGHTER]
--to talk about Dart because
as well as being a really
well-designed language, it's a
versatile platform for Flutter.
Dart doesn't just compile
to native ARM code,
but also compiles to tight,
production-ready JavaScript
code.
So I want to give you an
early glimpse of something
we're working on in the labs.
To be clear, this is
a technology preview.
We're not shipping
any code today.
We're calling this Hummingbird.
And it's a port of
Flutter that runs
on the modern
standards-based web.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm going to show you a little
demo of Hummingbird now.
Here's a simple mobile
app that we've been
running on an Android tablet.
It's an implementation of
the 15-tile sliding puzzle
that I suspect we
all know pretty well.
You know, I can move tiles
around and I can auto-play it.
We've done the usual
Flutter things.
We've added a little
bit of styling
to it to make it look beautiful,
and so on and so forth.
But I'm going to open Chrome
and browse to this page.
And everything
you're seeing here
is Flutter running on
the desktop web browser.
Everything you're seeing here.
[APPLAUSE]
Everything you're seeing here
is standards-based content.
HTML, DOM, Canvas,
JavaScript-- there's
no black box here any more
than any other web content.
Importantly, it's
the same Flutter code
running in this browser
as on the phone.
We haven't had to change the
codes to get it to run here.
We've still got some
optimization work to do,
but you can see that we're
getting 60 frames per second
for this scenario across the
current generation of devices.
And because this is the web,
I can even turn it into a PWA
if I want to thanks to the
great work from the Chrome team.
So that's Hummingbird.
What do you think?
[APPLAUSE]
Again, this is early days for
this experimental product.
Our Hummingbird, you might
say, is still learning to fly.
In the meantime, we are
publishing right now
a blog article that describes
more of the technical details
behind Hummingbird.
And we'll have a lot more to
share at next year's Google I/O
conference.
So portable, high
quality UI has been
the holy grail for front
end developers for decades.
And over the course of
the last hour or so, I
hope you've seen why we think
Flutter has the potential
to transform how all
manner of UIs are built.
This is not just
about iOS and Android.
This is about building
beautiful user experiences
on any platform.
We're excited about our mission,
and we hope you are, too.
So to close, I want
to introduce you
to someone who's played a
pivotal role in the Flutter
project.
Eric Seidel is one of the
co-founders of the Flutter
project and he's going
to end this presentation
with a few final thoughts.
Eric, thank you so much.
ERIC SEIDEL: Thank you, Tim.
[APPLAUSE]
Couple of my colleagues and
started this project at Google
over four years ago.
We just wanted to make
development better.
We wanted to make user
experiences better.
And these are themes
that many of us
had worked on for years as
part of the Chrome project.
But we felt that within
the constraints of the web,
we couldn't get
there fast enough.
So we started experiments to
see if we could make something
radically better for both
users and all the teams that
develop for them.
Those experiments
became Flutter.
So how we got here
was a bit interesting.
It took a little while.
But we felt a radical
approach was required.
If we were going to break
from existing systems
and build a whole
new way to develop,
we knew that was going
to take a long time.
But we saw this as an
important long-term investment,
not just for my team,
but also for Google.
So as we were starting, we
talked to lots of developers.
We sat down and made many,
many lists of problems
that we heard and
wanted to solve.
I think it's worth looking back
at at least the four big areas
that we set out to solve.
And you've heard some
about these today.
So the first was that
we wanted to make it
easy to build beautiful things.
And because, again, this
was a long-term bet,
Flutter had to make
it easy not just
to make the most beautiful
things available today,
but also had to be flexible
enough and powerful enough
to build the most
beautiful things being
designed for tomorrow.
The second was that
we wanted to make
it easy to boost consistent,
reliable performance.
We saw developers
struggle with this
consistently on other
platforms and we
wanted to make it
easy to deliver
a really smooth
experience at 60 frames
a second, 120 frames a
second, 240 frames a second,
whatever the underlying
device could do.
Third, we really wanted
to improve the developer
experience.
Develop productivity
has-- you know, again,
if we're making a long-term
bet, developer productivity
had to be at least as good as
the best available that day.
And so far, honestly, we've
far exceeded my expectations
with now sub-second,
stateful hot reload.
And fourth, we needed to build
a thing that could go wherever
Google needed it to go.
It had to be open.
It had to be extensible.
It had to be flexible to go
to all the places and all
the devices.
Run on all the
hardware, the software,
all the crazy things that
Google was building then
and is building now.
We spent many, many months
working with a few brave
early customers.
And many times in
response to customer
needs we rewrote large
swaths of the system.
But we always kept our eyes
on these long-term goals.
In the end, it was
a lot of effort.
Still is a lot of effort.
But I think the results
speak for themselves.
The many apps that
we've shipped--
or that we've seen
shipped, rather--
the success stories
we've heard continue
to tell me that we
focused on the right areas
and are getting good results.
Which brings us all to today.
So this, today, our
announcement of 1.0
is obviously a major
milestone for the project,
and for the community, and for
the many teams who have worked
for years to get us here.
You saw today how Flutter is
already enabling developers
all over the world to deliver
beautiful apps to hundreds
of millions of people
throughout the globe.
But this is also
just the beginning.
Flutter is Google's
portable UI toolkit.
It is highly portable and
already works on many form
factors beyond phones.
You saw it used today on
desktops for our slides.
You may have seen some of
the many articles floating
around the internet of people
taking Flutter and running it
on gigantic things or
little tiny things.
And you even saw today some of
our experiments with running
Flutter on the web.
So if I look
forward a few years,
I see Flutter running
in a ton more places.
So finally, and really, the
whole reason why I'm up here,
is to say a big thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I want to say personally
thank you to so many
for working with us for
so long to get here,
particularly those
who tried Flutter.
Some of you bet on
Flutter very early
on before it even
was called Flutter.
I also want to say thank you for
all the hundreds of suggestions
and bug reports that this
community receives every month
from those listening.
And finally, of
course, thank you
to those tuning in,
whether via one of our,
I think it's over 150
now, viewing parties
around the globe, via
Twitter, via the livestream,
and of course, to all
of you here in person.
So thank you for taking
time out of your day
to celebrate with us.
And fittingly, we're going
to close today's presentation
not with us, but with you.
Flutter has always
been and always will
be a community effort,
built together in the open.
No one company or
one team can reach
all of the places we
want Flutter to go.
So we close with our hats
off to that community.
The stories like we're about to
show you give us the motivation
to continue each
day in this mission.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]